thank you to Harry's and expressvpn for
sponsoring more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
she's a super freak super freak she's
super freaking yes
Andrew no I was more excited that you
did it then cuz the movie's freaky it is
freaky yes and I'm not a little
[__] I'll get a Chlor bomb Oh Jee je no
that really got me that was not a fake
reaction I promise you guys I how could
that have been fake I mean you just I
literally got as but you just look like
a little
[__] thank you how long have you been
waiting to tell everybody that you're
not a little bab I am you can let me
know in the comments I am it's all good
that's a good segue leave a comment like
subscribe tell Andrew he's uh a big
what's the opposite of being a little
[__] a big little [__] no he's a big
boy there you go he's a big male cat let
him know that you're excited that we're
watching freaky also thank you to
prepper for editing down this video for
always making us look good if you are
the sexiest of Rejects and go over to
patreon where you can watch along and
sync up with your own copy that's where
John and Greg cover several shows
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs over there I know literally
nothing about this movie you know one
thing Vince vonson it okay that's the
EXT of what we know I don't even know
what genre we're getting into apparently
came out during the pandemic and I paid
zero attention now I'm going to pay
attention my eyes are open for freaky
let's
go oh the Red Sun is this a DC spin-off
I didn't know communism Great Balls of
Fire you didn't know somebody could say
so much about an intro did you not till
just now Roxy
Beverly Hills
Productions sorry Blum housee I'm just
kidding I know that would irk you I
didn't know Blum House worked on this
huh whoa Wednesday the 11 you feel it
shaky I know what Friday is going to be
he moves through this town unseen like a
ghost and he kills a will every year my
birthday is on the 13th the butcher
killed some kids like in the '90s and
then 20 years ago he disappeared the
rest is just local folkore yeah where's
my Purge
pillow Purge every during homecoming
week to warn Blissfield teenagers of the
dangers of underage debauchery what
would this year's story
be that is not cool that's like Purge
Purge Purge I smell like cheap beer now
I like that she said I smell like cheap
beer she didn't just say I smell like
beer it's smell like cheap beer Zing
whoever bought this is so
poor
time to get freaky
freaky you did it I did it what is all
this [__] Jenny's dad's an art
collector that's pretty cool yeah your
face says that it's cool it looks like
he's going to vomit that's pretty
cool wow is there some spiritual
significance to this knife nah just a
regular dular knife
there's no way to open this thing are
you going to help me or
not uh not with that attitude my God
this so teenage angsty are you going to
help me or
not whoa did you see the glow there of
the knife
yeah ah people who collect masks are
always some kind of wonderful now that's
what I'm talking about
o
o that was a wild
shot
malet I'm not going to say it Purge
Purge Purge big cat nice one Sandra you
made me drop
it also why did he struggle to read that
so hard I just dropped glass yesterday
too got a nice nice cut from it this
looks so
what' you drop Dam it's not fun picking
up glass it's the little shards that get
you I love that the camera keeps
dropping to his level as we go down a
POV shot from something that's watching
him every time we pop up I'm like what's
there
yeah
whoa Adam's Apple
strong wow wow we're 5 minutes into the
movie
atude he might be
okay that was an intense first kill
usually first kills like they kind of
ease Us in this was like no we're not
aing around agroon knocking won't make
me move any faster he almost looked like
Jason from I I have to get a better look
at him it was really quick I know it's
not Jason but I just kind of look like
him now this is just going to be her
friend we're fine they're just setting
us up
oh oh oh oh hey
jeez oh my God that's an interesting
transition this movie comes hard and
fast I understood where you went with
that one but yes wait what about me
you're taking so did it's vagina not an
all night drive-thru could be both you
know that's really inconsiderate yeah
cuz guys are always so considerate maybe
a handy
you have to PE after you have
whoa those are very creative kills are
we doing that thing where he doesn't
walk
[Music]
fast doesn't
oh why would she go into the
house
woo
just the absolute dumbest move run away
from the house he's clearly one of those
Killers who can't move faster than that
from the back of his head I would assume
that's Vince Von I oh yeah the back of
your head is ridiculous but if it is
Vince Von we got to remove the mask
quick because you know that his agent
must have negotiated that he can't be in
a mask on right there's a hidden trap
door somewhere in
there
oh there really
was or
not multiple Coke closets all right
where's that dagger I saw it light up
earlier something's going to happen with
that
H neat trick okay but maybe stay there
like what are you doing oh he's going to
come behind her
somehow why would you come out you knew
you were safe in there this is bad it's
got to be such a mix of emotions going
from the pleasur bles of sex to the
horrors of being chased down by a killer
I was worried she was going to get a UTI
because she didn't pee afterwards but I
had bigger bigger F we know the issue of
that happening cuz we experienced it all
the time with reactions no
idiot ah like why would she just go
running when she the car like didn't you
remember he was still in the house like
yeah
okay I'm so sorry but it's silly cuz
it's been so
hard did you see the car at the end of
the driveway no I did nice ju to
position well if she does I'm
going it reminds me of when the parents
found Drew Barrymore at the beginning in
Scream one that's reminding you of that
yeah she's just hung up like that but
that was on a tree is it the
Beckers
and and how how quickly they killed her
and killed everybody but I didn't
recognize any of those actors at the
beginning and none of them were
Katherine Newton so I was like okay
we're all dead
right we're getting so close to Friday
the 13th do you have a date for
homecoming tomorrow I um I'm not I'm not
going she has a date with me we're going
to see Ricket at the anus theater did
you have to call it the
anus seems a little weird to miss out on
a seminal High School experience to go
see [__] regional theater you know it's
just underage drinking our night is
still ending in tragedy that would piss
me the F off if I ask open the jar but
if I'm trying don't take it from me she
opens the jar for her she berates
her oh mom's
drinking wonder why she's such a loving
older daughter yeah but the older
daughter has to be like this because her
how many times has her mom fallen off
the wagon yeah I get it do you a little
bit yes you and I both with living moms
we do
understand I have to make a DPC
reference every single stream can't get
through one without rise up now you're
going to miss the homecoming dance to go
watch some hag and green face hanging
from a wire it's just a stupid dance why
do you want to go anyway I have to shoot
it for your but I know her like
personally no oh the girl in the middle
I feel like she's some CW Show or
something it's been a year you can't
keep living your life for someone else
you've got to start doing things for you
yeah it's just it's not that easy my dad
was her whole world you don't want to
hurt your mom's feelings it's why I love
you I don't want you to wake up one
morning and realize your whole life
passed you by cuz you were busy being
everything to everyone but you it's
important situations like this having a
good support system nah overrated
yeah all right he needs to get the first
kill that was the most realistic moment
of the whole movie though that that be
happening in school yeah it does but he
needs the next kill I mean not first
love your dress thanks where you get it
I've had it a long time I think I saw it
at discount banan and I had to did your
mom used her employee discount wow
there's a lot of very nice people in
this film yeah
I wonder if there's that mean girl thing
that still goes on in high schools I'm
sure there is like that teenagers can be
cruel
Roxy but with delicate detail to the
window framing that was a great awesome
shot kill the call us their home Alan
Rock oh I'm in a movie with him oh
really yeah when Cameron was in Egypt
land be on the lookout for crust my
presentation is isn't scheduled till
next week this isn't debate class what
you said the 16th it's the 12th we know
that we know it's the 12th Miss Kessler
is holding up the class and once again
miss Kessler is
unprepared D something to add Booker
once again miss Kessler's dad died a
year ago be
nice is she an Instagram meme or oh wow
those moments are always so wild when
you get the Amber Alert things yeah
jinny was one of my best friends why
[__] please jinny hated ryler after she
started that rumor about Jenny getting a
carrot stuck in her P don't say that
word
[Applause]
whatever Strode Halloween reference Lori
Strode oh good one that was a good catch
okay reference King let's
go only Beaver no would
touch I mean you brown back her face she
sort of
doable God there are so many in this
movie I also don't get it she's
obviously pretty so it's super weird uh
yeah usually very beautiful girls like
that are not ridiculed to this extent
not say it brown bag her face she's
doable like what she's late again you
sure you don't want to ride she's the
main character we have to be empathetic
towards her I am because she's a good
actress there's a psycho roaming free no
I'm good there's plenty of people around
and she'll be here any minute I'm good
just
go a cute that was really cute can we
try
it
oh how do you think we did we did
[Music]
fine yes great work team
it's not a probably a good idea to be
alone what do you mean there's a killer
on the loose of course it's fine to be
alone when four teenagers just got
killed I think your mother is with a
bottle okay that was a good guess wow
when you're drinking you're not living I
know but can she not press the Uber
button maybe I know she doesn't have any
money maybe damn it h yeah I guess she's
a teenager probably doesn't
but man
chisel hi she's passed out on the couch
again can you come get you got to be
kidding me right
now okay but it's Katherine Newton so
she's got to live for at least another
hour unless they pull the psycho thing
right I'd haven't seen that movie but I
know what happens at the beginning
Psycho
Killer
coming she comes she'll be coming around
the mountain when she comes everybody
now she'll be coming around the mountain
she'll be coming around the mountain
she'll be slowed down around them oh no
we didn't even finish it oh my
God why please don't be the butcher
please like what do you mean please
don't be the butcher what do you think
he is could just be someone who's trying
to scare her my sister's going to be
here any second she's a cop please don't
be the Killer is his hysterical please
don't be the butcher please don't be the
butcher is he does he have the knife in
his hand that he got no
but cuz he was using a bunch of
different weapons I know this is the one
cuz we saw the shattered
[Music]
case oh take your [__] off oh
ah how did she get away from that how
did that bottom fit through that
[Music]
a when they come down to your level I'm
just
like oh dreary sense of tension she
thinks she's safe but she's obviously
not we're about to hear a boom shaka
laka you never know he might be
gone oh no oh no no bad bad bad bad bad
Purge Purge Purge she's going to get
pulled from behind pull from behind pull
from
behind why run towards
[Music]
him it's Child's
Play It's a voodoo magic
trick waa
oh oh it's like what stabbing her
stabbed him wait what get away from
her I don't know kind of weird that she
shot up in the air if I saw somebody
stab my sister you better believe I'm
shooting them yeah I mean I get she was
trying to scare him away but still like
stab your sister shoot
him
uh
people and he's
freaky super freaky so the supernatural
element of this is kind of interesting
it's like where are we going with that
where then he got blood cuz that wasn't
just her yeah he stabbed her and then he
got blood they're linked
somehow
uh let's go reveal what's going
on
ah like nightmare in NM Street in the
bathtub I don't worry I won't spoil too
much for you I know you haven't seen
those
films this is B to big part oh the
sister is ridiculing the mom yeah I
would too sh she would have picked her
up this would not have happened then we
wouldn't have a movie yeah oh yes cover
your face that will help I don't think
I'd ever close my eyes
again
oh my God is this going to be Freaky
Friday where they body swap ah could see
that the clock please be Freaky Friday
please body it's funny when we typed in
freaky uh on the to purchase the film it
said Freaky Friday was right below it is
this Freaky Friday oh my God that is the
funniest premise I've ever seen in my
life is that what it is body swapped
with a kill oh my God yeah I think
that's what it is oh my God oh my God
okay yeah that's what it is hysterical
oh God to go from slasher horror film
into this that's a interesting blend of
genres yeah because we were only how's
your shoulder 30 minutes in I was like
what is
this I wasn't really up far off when I
was making that joke about this being
like child's play with Voodoo that's
what it is it's body swapping
that's really good acting you could tell
she's not herself I'm going to give you
a minute and uh I made french toast with
your favorite caramelize bananas ooh I
cannot get over the premise of this
movie and that they just called it
freaky what a fun
homage and just incredible in general
this is
amazing did they say how the dad passed
or no just a year ago accident I think
they said I don't know hope it's not
revealed that it was Vince Von it's
going to be annoying if it's that it's
not something else so I don't want them
linked in some other
[Music]
way
come yeah would be an interesting
Discovery for a man oh God this is going
to be so crazy for her and his
body what a decrepit and interesting
place the second act of this movie is
about to be so weird where am
I that's why the cast Vin's F hello it's
the mannerisms I'm looking forward
to pin head that was a pin head
reference Hellraiser this is so cool
these
references like this is where he's been
living apparent
laugh
amazing amazing I was wondering why it
was Vince
vaugh Jesus oh my God he's definitely
got the Katherine Newton mannerisms down
you were just hallucinating hey you got
any jelly beans I'm sorry do I have
Jolly beans you know ice cubes uh
crunchy Munch some drugs man oh my God
no I I don't have any drugs what do I
look like like when you're seeing me
right now you know do I look like a girl
girl very petite blonde
it's like if you give me some jelly
beans you might you you you got get
drugs you're high right now oh no I
don't have the drugs come on man give me
someone that's good stuff I want to feel
like a teenage girl I want to feel like
a
girl come on come
back back I'll suck you all of
it all of it unreal that's worth the
admission of jelly beans wow I was
thinking we were just getting another
slasher movie and I was like all right
this is pretty good got you some fresh
pineapple you know how much you love it
good juicy one
too dude she's scaring the crap out of
me crispy like you like it me too got to
be
crispy oh oh my word okay all right I
guess you are hungry yes Katherine
Newton probably like to the director we
got to do this a bunch of takes I'm
hungry today how's Mellie well I think
she's a little bit in shock but she's
going to be be okay she's going to need
years of therapy uh she got a kill her
in her body now they just think that
she's like not well because of what
happened yesterday I thought you were
still
sleeping you stopped me from killing
your sister or she said a word not yet
honey I think you should go and get some
more rest you're not thinking of going
to school are you school I mean I know
your friends must be worried about you
but friends
I'm really enjoying her performance I
think this is such a funny concept such
depth who directed this who wrote this
good on you cuz I had no idea this is
where we were going until literally 2
minutes before we went
there I love how he runs in
this but imagine being a car hitting a
person and being mad at the person oh oh
my God I'm so sorry are you okay it's
you
it's him it's
him I'm obsessed with this movie this is
so
[Music]
fun I would imagine too when they're not
filming their scenes they have the other
actor there to make sure they're nailing
the mannerisms if they're available or
maybe they just spent like lunch
together or something you know
yeah oh my god
oh I doubt those girls are gonna mess
with her anymore they're gonna find out
what a perfect song selection right
now
s whatever will be will
be oh I can see what oh I feel bad for
Alan Ruck or actually I
don't I am having too much fun I'm
surprised she owned this
coat maybe she took it from her sister
or mom like why did did he put on red
lipstick he's seen it before in other
women now he doesn't hi have to hide
behind a mask are you okay ow smile for
[Music]
insta Millie you're Bliss Fields victim
we love you can you not such an annoying
girl
off and that police sketch of course
that guy's a killer that gross bloated
sweaty face and brown teeth ooh that
take me uh where some place private
something else happened last night
didn't it you can totally tell me I'm
like the most trustworthy person you
think she's dead or no there's a good
possibility of
that oh uh
hello you dumb
broad oh hello oh hello you're so dead
Mama wait are you I mean it's fine if
you are honestly Millie I'm missing AP
Bio I didn't come here to clam jam with
you clam jam I have to use that so I'm
going to go and when I get back you're
either spilling the tea or I'm out freak
freak she didn't come to clam
jam oh my God vegetarian she's a
Kuchar
oh she is dead your angel of Fate awaits
she is d e a d
dead is that the shower running yes
she's about to be bleeding in the
shower oh Vince Von in the oh that's not
what I thought was happening no it did
not
either oh my God the butcher's here he
we need to go you need to
hide is that in the cryo are you sure
this is safe
no oh my god oh no
ah they have a cryo thing in their
school that's crazy must be a private
school oh my
God damn she's going to be frozen on him
oh yeah oh my god well it technically is
him just in another body how are they
going to body switch back she's got to
stab him or
something
oh damn I mean what was that 5 minutes
well I guess that was pretty damn cold
so I can see it oh
smash Jesus good commercial for Apple
but the phone survived
right that's the most grounded
part but it's like how would he's such
like a how would he know what cryo did
hey how are you old now
lick it lick it
yes that's when you know it's meant to
be
H God damn it
Millie so sick of your constant need for
attention if only you would spend a
little less time flirting and a little
more time learning you might actually
make something out of yourself that's
your response to seeing her lick blood
off a kid's finger interesting need for
attention I'm just worried about her
don't freak
out guys F listen it's not what you
think come
on that hurts so much you're black I'm
gay we are so
dead stop running I'm not going to hurt
you it's me it's Millie sick how does he
know our name stop running please the
away from us will you live listen to me
for a second say something to prove who
you're who you are guys don't don't
really Josh guys stop will you stop Josh
start talking say how you know it's
them ow okay everyone's tired we've done
lots of hitting it's time to talk almost
feel like he broke her back let me
two say something that only they would
know words H
Blissfield our Battle Cry that reminds
me of big remember in big when he would
explain to his friend Shimmy Shimmy
Ro what's your favorite movie I tell
people it's Eternal Sunshine but it's
Pitch Perfect too favorite snack Triple
Berry Crushers oh my God love those
who's your biggest crush Booker
hooker Shake
[__]
choose
rule oh my God wait a minute
how what I need a friend right now and
it's like you guys are smashing the [__]
out of
me like weird old looking dagger but
when he stabbed me we both got hurt
standing in ping is kind of rad when he
stabbed me he instantly got a wound too
but in the exact same spot the left
shoulder and then late last night I kept
hearing the dagger's name like this
smoke weed but don't be such idiot about
it this is like three gallons of pee
this guy's platter is huge is everything
huge Joshua well you know this is the
boy room
right that's yes that's it that's the
dagger it's an Evidence locker room
dagger used in ritual sacrifice do I
wipe there's writing on
it I can't read it aren't you in Spanish
3 and your point you should be able to
read Spanish nobody pays attention in
that class dude Spanish to English
text what does it
say you know what she's saying a little
vatro so after after 45 hours if they
don't turn back then they're stuck like
this if the sacrifice is not successful
The Souls of the two persons are swapped
and the change becomes permanent after
24 hours 2 that's very child I said 45
24 sorry oh bente Quadro 24 hours I love
how this movie is very homage to so many
other horror films it's it's adorable so
gross my fart smell I didn't see what
that say one in the
stink Millie Kessler is a
gobbler oh my God are you serious I'm
not a
gobler hurry up loser I got to take a
dump and there other stalls I'm sorry
sir I I didn't mean to interrupt I I was
I was looking for for someone else
I how's that feel oh the kid who's
scared oh
yeah St your pants mess with Milly kler
or any other kid again I swear he better
be his pants
Roxy boom did you just
yourself it's disgusting such a movie
Trope yeah that's why I call that I'm
going to be stuck in this body forever
yep that's in like N9 hours it's doable
where's adola he at the police station
the evidence Locker we better get going
over there now it's good we got Stakes
now he's here somewhere he's wearing my
body and he's wearing my face he's like
a wolf and sheep's clothing and if we
don't capture him
first God knows how many people he's
going to kill I know but you should be
wearing a mask right now cuz everyone
knows what you look like change your
clothes at least haircut miss kley good
bye Al Ruck you got some nerve stepping
back in this classroom oh this is going
to be creative yeah put on those goggles
so it doesn't spur all over
you here's my presentation you're part
of
it prediction time Roxy how's she going
to oh never mind oh we know that she's
got the goggles so blood splatter oh my
God not off oh my God this is going to
be
[Music]
disgusting she's not that
[Applause]
strong
[Music]
yes oh yeah but he's Justified right now
I mean yeah just tried to kill him she's
gonna stab him right now of course it's
right next to her that's what you in the
ear with me
missing
oh oh you were close
yeah
jeez it's like pulsing out like a
heartbeat
[Music]
a
oh I wanted the splatter to be on the
goggles I want a goggle blood splatter
all right that's got to be the kill of
the film top kill of the film I mean
Jesus whoa what am I
wearing stop right
there
help help me R please help
me that's why you should have wear a
mask so she's
smart of
[Music]
[Applause]
course suspect spotted in a [__] Heap
the cops are like why are the two kids
taking him they're going to be looking
for us n could you move up a little more
we need to get you a disguise Mill you
can't be walking around in those clothes
with that face everyone knows who you
are good plan Nyla could you just do
just a little teeny teeny teeny teeny
just a little bit more this is me every
time I'm in the back seat like I can't
extend my legs are you tall I mean not
like super tall or
anything EXC headwest corner
of what are you kidding me [__] it's the
police it's my
sister
come
on good parking job no time to park
straight half to park crooked really
hide in here
quick do not come out until we get
[Music]
you oh I'm so sorry oh is that his mom
or her mom yeah remember works at the
discount store oh okay everybody needs a
second opinion how is the f because we
have lots of sizes just shut up and
drink some
chardonay I bought my husband a pink
polo one year for Christmas and he about
died Pink So Macho but guess what it
looked great on him oh I bet he loved it
I bet it was his favorite shirt oh I'm
so sorry I'm sorry I didn't mean to
share all that with you I just you're
just here trying to buy a polo for God's
sake no no no no no no no it's okay this
must be fun for you right
now you okay yeah I lost my dad I'm so
sorry you must miss him so much I do
well this is Dad's stuff my oldest she
shut down she retreated into work and my
other daughter she's so quiet now maybe
she just needs some some space I guess I
do smother her except when I'm supposed
to pick her up yeah and I'm too drunk to
get there she'll be graduating high
school and running off to college and
then I'll be left here she loves you
you're so easy to talk to yeah you're
great you're just your voice it's so
comforting and she going to ask him out
I've had such a good time talking to you
we hardly know each other I know I I
haven't even seen you yet but I think we
have a connection and you do have a
connection I'd like to know if maybe you
would like to grab a coffee with me
sometime oh God no a married man mom
have you talked to Milly today no I
hav't okay call her and make sure she's
okay was just cited again go let's go
come on to you oh my
god what the hell is that quick put it
on your scary Aaron Rogers now yeah
that's like quite a disguise Aaron
Rogers is already
scary say Vince Carter I can't breathe
it's all we had time to grab your
sister's on our ass let's go oh my God I
can't see [__] how did killers do this
Nyla Drive oh wait did they say Aaron
roders yes oh I thought it said Vince
car for some reason no want a party we
should throw one homecoming the butcher
okay sure and where are we going to pull
that off with lens's curfew the old
M no one would look there oh is that
where he lives who knew a little Mill
kesser could be such a Crafty Beaver
your touch makes this D than
sandpaper monkey I can't wait to kill
[Laughter]
you oh my God oh my God might be the
best line in the movie This T your touch
makes this drier
thaner you monkey I can't wait to kill
you or effing kill
you okay I'll go check the back you need
that knife though do you think Vince
Von's under that mask you mean or they
have just a stunt actor yeah I literally
can't understand you I think that's
Vince survive you go that way there's
probably times where it's not Vince Von
and then there's times where it is I
hope that Vince Von saves him right now
because I like him too and I want him
and Millie to have a first dance at prom
which I think might
happen don't be a little [__] what
about a big what was what was it big cat
big male
cat we hate this place I don't know if
the friends are going to Sur we'll see
who do you think's going to survive the
whole movie or right now the whole Mo or
I guess right now yeah I do think the
friends are going to survive how about
him yeah cuz I think that they've set it
up that that's her Crush so and we're
going to prom yeah but a lot of times
the crush doesn't survive in in these
horror films yeah but I think the other
dude is more apt to die I think Vince is
going to save
her make sure you're okay G to cut the
neck or go for the neck no he's
safeer
[Music]
oh [__] that's your face you just
hit don't let him get away he'll call
the
coops oh wow it's fod is just so such a
towering presence I he whacked the [__]
out of him or her he's still
out I I feel like kathern hudon got way
much tougher brunt of damage it's it's
like his soul in her so yeah true true
true this is going to sound really
strange Booker Booker look at me he's
crazy okay Booker can you look at me
please please Booker please can you look
at me just for a second oh my God so
last night our Consciousness or our
spirit whatever you want to call it it
traded places she's telling the truth so
he stabbed me with the DOA she's telling
the truth yeah I have like less than 6
hours to swap back or I'm going to be
stuck in his body forever you're all
going to jail for this you too Booker
unless you help me Boog up
[__] booger this is clearly not me have
you ever seen me dress like that I mean
I kind of like a a lot of what he's
doing with it but it's the point is that
you've never seen me dress like that
right do you like that it doesn't
[Laughter]
matter no I need to go right now you're
not going to stop me I'm going to freak
out okay I'm not yours not lost in you
not lost although I long to be oh my God
oh my God lost as a snowflake in the sea
you love me this is romantic this is
incredible leave me deaf and blind swept
milie oh I am in love with this movie oh
it's the concept of it it's brilliant
we're going to have to figure out how to
steal it and get it back here that's
like 40 minutes round trip there's
plenty of time right time is not our
friend right now where's the party is
that the Old Mill that's why I woke up
in this body he's luring in there that's
a trap then we better to get moving what
about her pronouns Christ what about him
prouns oh my God it is about your soul
that's hysterical oh yeah no I don't
think it's a good idea to leave him here
alone no he's right someone needs to
stay behind and keep an eye on him just
in case me it's your house definitely
going to die this time I would not want
to be left alone with Katherine Newton
SL Vince Von you guys stay here honk the
horn twice if you see anything okay
what's your plan don't worry about it I
got this how do you think she's going to
get the dagger back flasher
kidding he kidnapped us he made us drive
him I escaped but he followed me here
he's here outside behind the station
okay just just stay here okay hide under
my desk one cop in the entire station
she got a keys her keys and it's a small
town I felt oddly empowered being in
this body Invincible or kind of badass
oh my God oh my God it's like there's
these heartwarming moments throughout
that it's touching yeah in a slasher
horror film it's interesting blend of
genres also a romcom and I will stand by
that oh no I agree it's a blend of all
[Applause]
[Music]
hello oh no
Josh oh crap you're home early my last
leg got canceled honey why is Milling
tied to my dining chair good luck
explaining this we're role playing role
playing yes role playing like a game
sort of she doesn't look like she's
enjoying herself oh she is oh um that
that that's the point she's she's
supposed to act upset right
Millie she's method never breaks
character naughty
girl I'm a little confused isn't role
playing a game is it m it's a matter of
perspective I'm Bye Mom
I I didn't want to you until I was ready
but I'm straight oh my God I knew he was
going to say that amazing Joshua you are
many things but straight isn't one of
them now do me a favor and untie her
should have said I'm by that would have
been more selling can't explain right
now but I cannot let him go him no Mom
Mom Mom listen to me he's the Blissfield
butcher God Joshua Michael oh crap no
and the KN is right there yeah she's
going to die
run go go go go go
go watch out the knife through the
[Music]
door it's like Child's Play H should
have listened to your boy it's like we
knew there had to be more kills so his
mom had to come home because I don't
think the friend's going to die so yeah
that knife through the door reminded me
Child's Play so you said did you ever
see that one or no is that Chucky yeah
maybe first one so about that poem Oh My
Gosh please don't bring that up that was
a total mistake that was a mistake it's
so well you accidentally rode it and you
were just going by my locker and you
tripped and it fell in
exactly I thought it was beautiful the
poem probably like 100 times this actor
is probably on Cloud9 right now yeah
never did he think he was going to do
this scene with vin and he's awesome oh
he's great I really like this actor a
lot no you didn't Millie I've liked you
since day one oh my God I'm going to I
I how weird is it that I kind of feel
like kissing you right oh my God
please oh my god do it do it I'm so
excited right now this is you'd be
kissing a mass murderer with yellow
teeth you're still mly to me oh my God
oh my God oh my
God maybe we should wait for when my
hand's not bigger than your whole face
it's it's whenever you want I was not
expecting that I was hoping they would
do that that was so great Millie stay
out of this I'm just trying to help I
don't need your help okay just help help
back up
shark
oh friend damn start walking towards the
cell come on so hard to explain this to
people it's not a very believable thing
start saying facts about about her start
saying what you know our mom's a drunk
our dad died a year ago well that I mean
that's public knowledge in a small town
yeah but just start just start
talking I'm so sorry I really thought
your hamster could swim and I'm so sorry
that Regal died but this is all going to
make sense to you later on I really
thought your H I thought your hamster
could swim so you think you're this hot
[__] now huh you I've never made
anyone's dry you make M dry every second
you speak oh you are so gone I don't see
him surviving at all no obviously not
and we don't care we want him dead this
is way too dangerous there is no way
we're not helping you Mel we're in this
together 13 minutes left Jesus here come
here come here Us in set of
timer time to stab this [__] it is so
laid out perfectly timing wise
structure-wise this is like a perfect
script I am blown away by this movie
right now look like we got a little
private party going here huh are you
good at math M cuz the way I see it you
have three holes and oh my goodness my
God kill them all they were not afraid
to go all out in the scripts no and
we're rooting for her now so hard uh
yeah oh she's going to break it cut him
open
oh
ah
[Music]
oh it makes me so queasy with the
necky what are you doing
stop it's so smart because we want we're
rooting for the butcher right now I'm
sorry I'm sorry
please oh right in the nut sack oh you
are not going to be able to use that
again Millie oh yeah I uh I saw her
really where uh this way are they going
to kiss what is he on drugs and I feel
like they're going to kiss oh why I
don't know did you get sexual attention
I'm not going to I don't say that he
might be closeted and he hiding
it
oh Phil I don't have time for this
we're oh you caught Vibes I did not you
tell anybody I'll kill
[Music]
you I Know What You Did Last Summer yes
get out of here what are you doing
go I like this Arc for Millie though
like you know going from this Dam Zone
distress to the hero Brave heroin I want
my body
back come and get it come and get
[Music]
it
[Applause]
oh drop the
knif [__] this is such an interesting
reverse oh my God he's so slow
[Music]
yeah
catch
hold what time is it do it now do it
now only one way to find out just do it
where's the Bell what the Bell it didn't
hold Pro tip always set your watch 5
minutes
ahead hold him down no
[Music]
no yeah but doesn't the transfer happen
at midnight it's another 5 minutes right
whatever I don't even care okay yeah but
they got to get him I was going to say
who's your favorite
athlete uhoh oh at least the cops are
there no one I hate Sports freeze shoot
that mother
[Music]
yeah perfect timing I love Vince Von's
performance in this film too he's so
good like he was scary as hell and then
when he was as Mill he was like oh I
love him hey sorry to interrupt time to
land that plane girl yeah lost the
shoulder honestly the best pain I've
ever felt the voice change again what
are you going to tell the cops a version
of the truth I guess let's just hope
nobody ever gets her hands on that thing
I was going to say you should take
possession of that are we ready to try
that again I don't know let's see oh my
God I love him and I love
her so cute I am like obsessy in love
with
them oh no what's going
on is that his his body he's not dead oh
no how imp pathetic oh this SE the
Carnage sequel bait well they said the
thing about the knife
too ah oh he took it off yeah he's still
alive and he knows where they
live please don't end the way I think it
might what are you think is going to
happen I don't know I'm just it's a
horror movie It's just sometimes it ends
in a bad way there's no way may be
ambiguous but you think he's going to
kill her answer the question no I hope
not no we're going to see that her and
her body is still Fierce now
sh you left the door open again oh did
he stab sh with the knife you left the
door open again is weird for a cop's
sister like is she always leaving the
door open it's a small town I mean but
if there is a butcher on the Lo open not
unlocked
open
ah what with gunshots what's the matter
meling she'll be fine that what you
wanted right she's going to prove she's
tough got your body back weren't you
shot like
freeze what little girl shouldn't play
with
guys
whoa
oh [__]
not the TV Millie's going to save the
day cuz strong I think I think you're
right
yeah come on Millie you've been fleshed
out you've had your
Ark I understand why you feel so weak
you feel so meager kick him in the BS I
learned something when I was in your
body too what's
that
ah
yes
take
whoa I don't care how tough you are
getting kicked in the balls is not easy
to keep going on
through I feel like where are the
gunshot wounds I don't see any he has a
lot of black t-shirts through back on
over I am
peace I am a what I am a piece a
piece what was that a reference to I
don't know I would say a badass Michael
Kennedy and Christopher Landon unreal
job
unreal cool the the post credits are
even cool what isn't cool about this
movie Lori Rose you crushed it you DP
this is like
I mean is this one of the greatest
movies ever it was amazing I loved it
big thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got got a couple of
months ago so I was paying the
consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years
ago that made expressvpn my go-to for
both security and freedom I mean it and
yes what you've heard is true believe me
this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on
Netflix that are not available in your
country this means accessing a vast rate
of content of over a 100 countries like
a global cinema at your fingertips it's
super easy open Express VPN switch
locations refresh the browser and there
you have it whether it's kramas on South
Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube
or more expressvpn has you covered and
it's incredibly fast ensuring no
buffering or lack for smooth HD
streaming it's versatile too working on
not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means
you can enjoy your favorite shows on
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com reject so head to
expressvpn.com rejects to learn more
thank you again thrilled to be
partnering with a brand I've been using
for nearly 2 years now and that's
Harry's Razors I'm generally more drawn
to anything that goes against the norm
and Harry's does just that in The
Grooming World they saw the high prices
in the industry and decided to blaze
their own trail with quality and
affordability I keep a beer but whenever
you see these cheeks in the neck clean
and that's the work of Harry's right
there keeps my wife happy and Harry's
makes it effortless they're Precision
Blades that cut smoothly with less drag
making every shave satisfying and yes
it's versatile for other areas too you
know what I mean so as a Harry's devot I
can vouch for their value you can
experience unparalleled comfort and
quality in your grooming routine or
exceptional craftsmanship meets
affordability making a smart choice for
a top- notot shave without breaking the
bank their kits and value packs for
shaving are unbeatable but Harry's is
not just about shaving again they offer
top quality thoughtfully designed
grooming products including shampoo
conditioner and amazing body wash
without the premium price quality
affordability that's a thesis of this
now these I actually pulled right from
my own bathroom I regular L use their
five blade razor with a nice weighted
handle and their foaming shave gel man
this that oh it is a game changer I just
like the feel of it now I have to commit
to keeping this in my hand the whole
time cuz I'm not going to go to the
bathroom in the middle of shooting this
the handles they feel perfectly balanced
and the razor Sleek design is a classy
addition to my bathroom and the quality
of the shave unparalleled got to
reiterate ke part of my weekly grooming
ritual cuz their entire range of
products fits seamlessly into my routine
definitely no re-shoot here their German
engineer blades are durable and refill
plans are economical rarely use the word
economical but I'm using it now plus
their commitment to high customer
satisfaction and no risk trial makes
Harry's a no-brainer this Jael really
does feel good let me say once more
choosing Harry's means quality and
affordability by grabbing your $13 trial
set for just $3 at harry's.com reex
you're not only getting a great deal but
you're also supporting this channel
that's harry's.com reex for your $3
trial set stay sharp and embrace the
extraordinary with Harry till next time
reject Nation till next time we did
listen to it very loud yes we did that's
why I became a big cat at times at some
points I couldn't even hear you oh yeah
I couldn't either um by the way if you
are listening to us on Apple or Spotify
if you don't mind giving us a rating
we'd really appreciate it uh yeah no I
mean I didn't know what to something
else
too something else I don't remember what
Greg said make sure oh trivia oh yes yes
yes here let's that's
well I I figur at some point we would do
that you remembered you remembered to uh
pull up wait I'm curious how I know that
girl and Alan Rock so cool oh here we'll
we'll look her up too we're going to
look up some trivia for you guys at Nyla
right act BL Nyla was it Nyla oh she was
in Ghostbusters the new one is that how
I knew her that's right she was lucky in
Ghostbusters Celeste o Conor oh yeah but
I feel like I saw her in a TV show
once no I didn't a Wetlands no she just
started in 2017 maybe I saw her in a car
how I knew yeah yeah I saw that too I
just for some reason I I kept picturing
a CW Show or something yeah I knew she
looked familiar but it was clearly from
uh Ghostbusters afterlife uh here let's
look up some fun facts on trivia before
we get into our review because I know
Roxy and I got a lot to say the original
name of the film was Freaky Friday the
13th
that's but freaky is amazing
Freaky Friday the 13th I would have
known what they were doing and with just
freaky I didn't put the pieces together
until we got there Katherine Newton was
the first choice for Millie but she
originally declined however after
speaking with Jason Blum about the
project she eventually changed her mind
y Jason Blum called her direct and was
like listen babes this is going to be
sick I got to imagine to reading this
script like what an amazing opportunity
it be hard to read though I mean you
wouldn't know like what the tone of it
is right that's true I just got to be
like depthwise like this is a fun role
or roles to play she was so great that I
can't imagine it being someone else and
clearly Jason Blum couldn't either he
was just like no no it's got to be
kathern
Newton so Vince vom was already signed
on and kather Newton was like
n uh it doesn't say who signed on first
but it does say the bulk of the movie
takes place on Friday the 13th which we
know the film was released on Friday
November 13th 2020 damn it was a Scorpio
meta at the football game Booker's last
name of Strode is seen on The Jersey
this is a reference to slasher icon
Lorie stro Jam Lee Curtis of the
Halloween series saw that in addition
Blum House previously made Halloween in
2018 into a Trilogy this we know yep
Vince vongh told the Stunt Driver to
actually hit him with the car when he
was crossing the street early on in the
film The Director said Von said he could
take the hit and he did oh my God damn I
mean he's built like a train so I don't
do that yeah I'm sure the insurance
compan like yeah go for it um director
co-writer Christopher Landon cited
Fright Night the blob scream scream to
urban legend Cherry Falls and Jennifer's
Body as Inspirations for this film I can
see that the Jennifer's Body stuff cuz I
watched that for this channel also it
tonally totally because of that horror
comedy thing that that like thin balance
and also the sexiness of it yeah totally
yeah this was so good yeah I haven't
this movie was so good oh I loved it I
haven't seen Jennifer's Body but
obviously I know what happens she gets
like possessed or something in that
right and then she like totally changes
so I could totally see the inspiration
for that I mean there was so much love
and homage to so many horror films in
this film I from nightmare in Elm Street
in the bath to scream with being found
Austin Witherspoon you think that's Rees
Witherspoon something probably who knows
kather Newton played Rees Witherspoon's
daughter in big little eyes oh maybe the
Pitch Perfect 2 poster in Millie's room
is actually the poster from the first
Pitch Perfect film film but for some
reason has the text of Pitch Perfect 2
why do you think I don't know but I
never would have noticed that yeah
that's bizarre um let's find another one
there's so many interesting ones on here
um what do you want IMDb yeah Vince faon
also played a serial killer as I
mentioned as Norman Bates in the remake
of psycho and as Lester long in clay
pigeons so he's not unfamiliar with
playing these type of roles it was that
transition though right I love how he's
able to be fear
but then him being able to embody not
just like being a young girl but being
Katherine Newton as a young girl
specifically like when he would throw
his hands up I mean they must have spent
a lot of time together learning each
other's mannerisms yeah well I think
also too you probably said like even
during like lunch breaks and stuff like
that they were probably like just going
over with each other cuz I mean I you
know kind of like mentioned face off I
really feel like John travol and
Nicholas Cage they nailed the mannerisms
like that's what sold me on that movie
was like thinking like this character is
actually that character I mean you got
to get the mannerisms I wonder if for
this they filmed all of the scenes in
their own bodies first so that they
could observe each other like the end
scenes and beginning scenes and then
they went into all the middle chunk so
that they could kind of like see and
play off of each other's that's a good
point I I mean I would imagine that
would be probably the way I would do it
it depends on money obviously like set
stuff but that like a smaller budget
film even though it it yeah Vince Von's
fall during the auditorium Chase was
accidental and not scripted V slipped on
the fake plant that was knocked over and
lost his balance but he continued on
through the scene okay in the opening
sequence when the butcher kills his
final victim with the spike on the wall
he tilts his head the same way Michael
Myers did in Halloween after stabbing
the victim on the wall see homages to
all the other ones the poem that Millie
placed in Booker's Locker which he
recites to him is I am not yours by
Sarah
Teasdale fun stuff fun stuff let me see
that was well we can be done with the
the trivia portion of this now this
one's for you Greg we did it we did it
yes way to go sorry I have a ring on I
probably just all good I I barely felt
it um I barely feel anything ex what was
the deal with the line at the
end I am a piece I would have liked I'm
a badass but you guys let us know in the
comments
piece I I don't know must we must have
missed some line earlier um but I I
thought it was just so brilliant uh like
blend as we mentioned during the
reaction just blending all the genres
like slash horror uh romcom and then
also the supernatural element I just
like but it was executed in such a
meticulous and fun way and scary way it
just like when you blend all these
genres like just telling me about it I
would have been like I don't know if
that's going to work but then actually
watching it the way it was executed in
the film and uh the way it was portrayed
I was like I loved every second was
actually fun and scary at the same time
and it so it was great and I love the
arc too Millie went through throughout
the film like again she's you know
obviously she has this loss that she has
to deal with with her father it's gotten
uh obviously it's affected her family
kind of a broken household and you know
she's obviously it's it affects her at
school people are extremely mean to her
and she kind of uh you know kind of a
weak character in terms of just like you
know from taking things on mentally and
physically too obviously she was
attacked by the butcher not really much
you can do with him anyways in terms of
physically battling him but I just love
this transition she goes throughout the
film she's a really fully fledged uh
fleshed out character and I love by the
end like it's actually fully earned like
I bought that she you know killed him at
the end like that was fully believable
after everything she had gone through
and all the you know physical and mental
turmoil she had gone throughout the film
I I loved her transition towards that
badass at the end I agree and I think to
what you're speaking about this movie
made some very smart choices number one
they could have ended it right when
Vince vongh when they switch back bodies
and he gets shot but they didn't because
they wanted to show the full Arc of her
that she is changed in her own body it's
not that she could defeat him because
she was in his body it's because it's
inside her the whole time and so I
thought that was really brilliant along
with a lot of other choices they made uh
just to not have to for the first 25
minutes for the First Act of this movie
to have us think okay we are coming out
the gate strong this is a slasher film
even though we know some Supernatural
there's this lore with this knife we're
seeing like okay what could this be as
we had uh the almost like Aztec set up
and everything going on you're like what
is this and then you realize freaky
freaky Friday just so so brilliant and
also I I think that when we when we are
talking about a lot of movies on this
channel you we'll talk about the
performances we'll talk about the
dialogue we'll talk about the DP uh or
the cinematography which in this was
unbelievable the music but often times
it's not the premise that makes the
movie and in this movie it's the premise
I love the premise like this is the best
elevator pitch ever it is Freaky Friday
but you're swapping bodies with a serial
killer yes that's the whole movie and
then they just they knew they had it
they were like oh that premise is Bomb
now let's play around like crazy so once
they they really believed in their
premise and they were like we're not
going to shy away from this this is wild
we're going to make it so that she has
to in his body convince our friends
convince the guy she likes they have
that conversation in the backseat like
they did they played with us in every
way possible and into this premise that
they created I just think this movie is
a perfect script it's perfect for people
who are looking to write a film like it
hits every Mark in terms of its act
structure and how much fun it's
having like this is one of the best
movies that I've seen reacting on this
channel it was perfect it was great and
it's a shame too it came out during Co
because I before yesterday I never even
heard of it I didn't know I've never
heard it until today we sitting yeah
Greg texted me like have you ever seen
freaky I was like I've never even heard
of it um and then I I the only thing I
saw mdv was cuz I just wanted to see who
the cast was I didn't look up the the
premise uh cuz Greg said dude please
don't look up the premise I want you to
naturally see what happens uh so I just
saw that Vince vaugh was in it um
because I just wanted to see which
actors were in the film um but then like
being naturally surprised like like you
said in the First Act of one uh the
first part of the act one like we just
see it's a slasher film is what I
thought we were in for and then to be
naturally surprised like oh my God no
there's going to be a blend of genres
here and I you said they just really
stuck the landing and I just was they
didn't do the thing you were worried
about what was I worried about that he
was going have killed her dad oh thank
yeah and again when you were talking
about just nailing like down tropes and
all that I mean there were a couple
things that were tropy but they were
self-aware and kind of met which I
appreciated uh but yes I'm so glad and
honestly it would have made sense if
they would have said he was the reason I
mean obviously there's a me a morat of
reasons that the father could have
passed away in terms of you know human
beings um passing away but obviously
this butcher clearly is terrorizing this
town so that could have been you know I
mean I would have accepted it I just
didn't want them to be linked that way
so I'm really glad that they steered
away from that because that is a a
horror tropy thing that I'm glad that
they stayed away from yeah me too
especially because I think that it's it
is not to get into my whole issue with
Man of Steel but it the point of a lot
of these things is like there's things
in life you cannot fix you cannot change
and then there are things that you can
fight for and you be can become the best
version of yourself the most badass
version of yourself and you can fix and
solve and like whatever happened to her
dad I didn't want the point of this to
be that she could have saved him you
know like they could have found this guy
she could have I think he just had an
accident but the point of this with him
is that when he first was coming for her
there was nothing she could do until she
became the most best version of herself
and and then she realized she was strong
enough and it was inside her just really
really great storytelling I can't also
describe enough how I think that the
movie was made by kathern Newton and
Vince Von oh yeah nailing this yeah
their performan again it's the
mannerisms and before I continue on that
I really think I understand now how her
father passed away he was probably
caught up in a tornado she had a chance
to super speed in she didn't she chose
to hide her vulnerability I can't hear
you anyway no I cannot yes but uh
getting back to this uh choking aside
getting back to this uh and she just
lets him die I know right hey it's it's
I understand not a heart attack you're
there I I how is that Superman I I I
understand what Snider was going for
even though I disagree with it but let's
get back to this um we'll talk about
this off camera um but it's the
mannerisms in their performance and I
just love to like in the beginning to
and also to the depth of like before I
get to Vince Von like Katherine Newton's
performance like at the beginning as I
was mentioning earlier seeing her like
just so D like damil and distress type
of like when you saw her running from
again you don't expect her to put up a
fight against Von's like three times her
size um but just like again taking the
mental abuse from all the the people and
like like the way she's coming off uh
you know and also like having to deal
with her father and then like when she's
scary as hell with Vince Von's soul in
her body and then like when you see her
as a badass like it's just such an
amazing depth of range in her
performance and vice versa when you get
to Vince Fawn he is scary as hell in the
first like 15 20 minutes and then the
yes how about this I love the little
[__] in the but like he's nailing it's
it's the mannerisms when he's nailing
like he's really convincing me like I
mean that he is Catherine Newton in and
not an obnoxious like I'm a girl yeah no
it it could have like could have been to
your point it really could have come off
as extremely obnoxious and and yeah cuz
there's so many ways to to mess that up
and he didn't he really nailed his
performance as Katherine n it you know
something else smart that they that I
felt like oh wow this could have gone so
wrong and you guys did this perfectly
they only killed people we wanted dead
that's true except for the very
beginning obviously we don't know those
kids but they did seem kind of obnoxious
right like smelling cheap beer we didn't
really know them to but they didn't like
I love that they didn't kill the two
best friends um I thought that the two
best friends were awesome supporting
characters they didn't kill the mom they
didn't kill the sister they didn't kill
kather Newton's character they didn't
kill the crush they killed I thought the
the crush was going to die I knew he
wasn't because we needed the real kiss
they killed Allen Rock's character they
killed the the [__] that tried to
straight up sexually assault oh my God
that was they uh they only killed they
killed the mean girl in school in the
crowd
uh by the way let us know in the
comments section I don't care but do do
other than private schools do they
really have cry freezers in I mean that
was the least believable thing not not
the not the uh the voodoo Supernatural
stuff that was the least believable
thing to me but I I went to public
school but I grew up in like a a nice
neighborhood we didn't we don't have
stuff I went to an extremely extremely
rich public school I know if there is I
know it's it was free but a lot of you
should have seen you should have seen
the parking lot mercedesbenz Galore same
thing look at us I know right well isn't
it nice yes right yeah uh but anyways
yeah um but no cryo machine yeah no cryo
I mean I don't even think cryo was a
thing when I was in high school anyways
uh another thing I appreciate in this uh
film I loved uh the camaraderie and the
teamwork between the three friends they
were so good together I want you to know
I drove a Honda Civic I drove a
Trailblazer so just I I wanted to be I I
I wasn't the super rich kid I saw all of
them but I oh no I drove all them like
have it was my brother's car and he let
me take it I I appreciate I liked my my
Trailblazer it was cool too and G gas
was uh you know not too bad priced at
that point so was six yeah right um but
I what do you think of the the three
friends together cuz I loved the their
chemistry together the interactions
there were so much fun and then also too
was really I like that to me it it felt
very reminiscent to Big when he was
trying to convince I believe Billy was
his young friend was Tom hanks's
friend's name uh when he was trying to
convince him like I'm I'm really J
Shazam I was thinking
of oh yeah good point this is all DC
Talk I don't know if his name was Billy
but I'm with you what I thought of the
friends is that I thought that they were
awesome that the girl was so good the
the um Catherine's best friend yes what
was did you say her name was I think
Nyla N I think she was so good that I
was convinced that I knew her from a
show somewhere because I was like well
she on the flash like what do I know her
from and then it was Ghostbusters but
she was so good and so endearing
immediately that I thought that I knew
her and then the other guy I had never
seen before but I was like he is funny
and quick um I even liked like when
getting his mom in the scene and seeing
how they're interacting and him being
like and I I love that moment cuz
usually it's like they come out and
they're like I'm gay and then he came
out he said stra she hone hear a lot of
things that's not one of them um he was
going to say I'm by just kind of
normalizing so I thought that was great
too but I love those friends and then I
really love the significant other or the
the
crush it was great that we like added
him on to the dynamic and then he came
in all the right moments um and I just
thought he was so sweet and charismatic
and that you believed he had chemistry
with Vince vaugh in the back seene in
the back with vin he like you said he
must have been on cloud n when he was
filming that scene he's like I just did
a a romance scene with Vince vaugh what
like and the context of the scene too
it's just so great uh so so great this
movie could not have been better I mean
is I mean pick for me do you have that
last line I don't I didn't get it I must
missed
something oh the the pie that's my only
nitpick I'm like what was that I should
have understood um yeah I guess that um
I don't know just so many people were
pieces of shits in this I guess but I
mean that's I guess that's real life you
know people some people can be pieces of
shits um but also too that makes you
know that makes them fodder to to get uh
you know annihilated I guess so um yeah
we're rooting for the kills so smart
yeah exactly um I don't know not really
too much I again I I loved it I love the
the blend of genres all this I thought
it was very fun while also at the same
time you know it made me be a big cat at
the same point too I was I got scared at
moment Purge Purge Purge I got I got
scared I got scared plenty um so and I I
just I love the performance as the
premise I thought heartwarming stuff
yeah was yeah like even in the when when
Vince vongh uh was as Cather in the
dressing room I thought that was so
sweet and endearing it was beautiful I
mean th this movie spoonfed me exactly
what I wanted couldn't be happier with
it going to recommend this to everybody
yeah like this is one of those hidden
gems where you're like have you seem
freaky you got to go see freaky yes all
right well if you have seen freaky you
just did because you watch with us then
like comment subscribe tell us what a
big group of cats we are me especially I
know and that's all reject see you next
time
[Music]
later